- I did not realize how tall you were!
- I am a giant lady
- No you are not!
You're like a sexy model!
I was like, "Damn, I didn't know!"
I don't know you don't know how people
are on TV, I'm such a fan,
I'm goofing out right now.
- [Hannah] You are, oh my God.
- Have you met Joseph?
- No, I feel like I've won a competition.
With both of you.
Spend the day with two people you love,
seriously.
- Oh my gosh, really?
- I don't know who-
- [Joseph] That's so nice of you.
- to look at first.
- Oh my gosh well okay so I'm just going
to say this and then I'll let it go.
I also loved you in Game of Thrones.
- Thank you (laughs)
- [Kelly] But here's the thing
(crowd cheers)
like first of all, I heard
that you kept the bell
from shame shame.
- [Hannah] Yes.
- [Kelly] That's kinda messed up! (laughs)
- Well that's also that's when you know
your character's really dead,
when they give you like the hero thing
of your character, they're like,
"And thank you very much and goodbye."
- [Joseph] (laughs) Yeah.
(kelly laughs)
- Oh, oh.
- We don't need this anymore.
- I know but that was
such a crazy big show too.
- [Hannah] Oh God it was insane.
- Like everything you touch
is gold apparently, yeah.
- [Hannah] It was insane.
- I've just been, I feel like
I've been very lucky that these huge shows
have just gone, "Come in and do this,"
and I, you know, it's just intense.
- Well you're lovely
and you're captivating
and I'm obsessed with your character.